[Music]
i thought the point was to prevent me
from turning into a hulk these
transformations are triggered by
distressed emotional states so we need
to know the exact threshold that causes
it for you the triggers are anger and
fear those are like the baseline of any
woman just existing all right then let's
try this
[Music]
i feel like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die you have a plan b for that ah
nope you're just gonna kill me
[Applause]
[Music]
wow jesus what the hell man still in
control and the overwhelming feelings of
rage no a normal amount of rage you do
revert back to gen 4 when you sleep was
the air horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face of
jennifer wallace
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil bonski i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
jen do your thing god i really like this
outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answered to a higher
power our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american uh laws
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
[Music]
you